what's happening reject nation we're
gonna watch today
shang chi teaser fight stunt share by
simulu
shang chi himself from marvel phase four
we're gonna watch cosmic wonders video
our good friend our sexy friend is
growing in subs
every day only because of us yeah you're
welcome
welcome you're welcome we've literally
saved your channel
yeah it was dying it's not the other way
around let's do this
stop trying to hit me
the matrix go to the matrix
yes that's good
maybe i start trying okay
now you're gonna start trying i see you
i'll see you
whoa
[Music]
dude
dude if we get this kind of fun
she looks at the camera
[Music]
what's going on everybody we gotta get
that kind of fighting in the movie we
gotta get that kind of fighting a little
teaser
and the references the tin rings is
going to be like
this morning actor simul liu who of
course is going to be playing shang chi
in the upcoming film
shared this video on twitter with the
caption messed around
with some legendary talented friends in
sydney last year
then he listed the few people in the
video what's really awesome about this
video is
it really is a teaser of what's to come
in chiang chi and the legend of the ten
rings that's because the three people in
this video fighting are all actually a
part of shane
action designers of shanghai and zac
is a part of the stunt team so this is
what the action scenes
that's what i'm talking about a lot of
fans were kind of worried that the
action and the fighting sequences were
going to be a little like iron fist
but this video that cemu shared shows us
thank god they're not
saying
who is absolutely incredible at fighting
and filming fight sequences
there's also a lot of fighter in this
video that seem to share
personality really shines it leads us to
believe that not only is shang chi going
to be
absolutely actionable
this combined with an insanely good
story you know marvel is going to do for
shang chi makes this movie a very
highly anticipated film coming up next
year and in phase four
so let me know what you think about this
video in the comments down below let me
know how excited you are for shang chi
and the legend of the 10 rings be sure
to like the video and subscribe so you
don't miss out on any of the latest mcu
news and so you can enter this week's
giveaway for a chance to win a modoc
funko pop from the avengers game
provided by heroes yeah that looks great
man for live updates you can follow me
looks great
and twitter follow the warnings thanks
so much for watching thank you for
putting that out
man okay okay all right so for the
longest time
we've been saying so we've been saying
because i grew up on hong kong
cinema i've been wanting the fight
scenes to be represented of something
like the yu and moo ping type of
fighting style
mixed with a little bit of what we've
been getting with modern day
sensibilities with films such as like
the raid and whatnot
you might have heard me say this before
already and then seeing the choreography
here which is
obviously not a fight from the movie
itself seeing the choreography here
knowing knowing they're all involved
makes the biggest difference because
when they do fight scenes nowadays um
especially for movies on this caliber a
lot of the times the stunt coordinators
the fight choreographers what they end
up having to do when working with the
directors for marvel
is they have to forget the technical
terminology they have to do it for the
john wick films and a bunch of other
movies where the stunt coordinators will
actually
shoot it themselves so that way the
directors can get us
and they usually for the most part
mirror what the stunt coordinators are
putting on display
in terms of how to even capture it on
camera and so knowing they're all here
doing the fight it looks like we're
gonna get the fight scenes
i know we've been wanting when i say
wee-wee but i also know wee-wee as in
us that's the correct word
anyway i was totally dazzled by that
that's great 100 agree i mean just the
fact that yeah you've got these three
people who are intimately tied to the
action in this movie showing you
something that is both
spontaneous spontaneous feeling but also
probably a good indicator as to what
kind of energy they're going to be
bringing to this movie this was super
exciting because yeah like i like marvel
movies i think
they are capable of some spectacular
action but this movie has me craving
a more tangible and a more classic
martial arts flair and this
was just so exciting because even the
martial arts films we get here in the
west predominantly now are
very hyped up and i'm sure this is gonna
have a lot of effects and a lot of
fantasy in it but to have something that
roots
in this classic tradition and that just
looks so energetic and fun i mean
granted yeah this isn't footage from the
movie but just like the charisma of
these three in general was great like i
love this john i gotta ask you
what's that i think you should wear more
bracelets
i'm going to wear i think you need more
bracelets i think you need more
bracelets you should be wearing
uh-huh then we could really start
getting some strong instrumentals going
on yeah when we're talking about the
music bedroom yeah these videos
yeah just shake it up yeah i like goes
man i i'm telling you
right now we're no no keep it on
music people are like maybe throw people
music people hit us up all the time in
our emails
yeah hey this gets copyrighted if you
need some background music
let us know i'm gonna i feel like john's
already kind of gone i'm gonna claim the
video
on my own behalf because this was an
original piece by me that i didn't give
you
permission to use on our behalf anyway
segwaying back i gotta say simulu
his personality i'm not familiar with
you know anything he's really done
so seeing his personality on display
here i was like damn
this good does have that leading man
charisma
i'm excited i didn't even really think
about his personality
i just wanted to see the fighting so
when seeing his personality on display
i'm like this guy looks like he'd be
funny and i'm not sure exactly what tone
it's going for
this particular film but a lot of times
these marvel leads have to have the
ability to capture humor of course
charisma
and he looks just just this little tiny
bit seem like the perfect amount on
display
of yeah that's that's like a marvel lead
an asian guy
being the marvel lead i'm so excited
pinoy pride
even though he's not filipino pinoy
pride
kick it in here yeah yeah right as much
as you want man
i gotta say you know like i don't know
which fights are gonna be better
between daredevil and this one in terms
of hand-to-hand martial arts fight
choreography for marvel
i feel like for my personal taste it's
probably gonna end up being this one
whereas like daredevil does have amazing
choreography
and their one take sequences especially
are incredible
they are a little bit more of the
grounded brutal
combining more of like yeah the martial
arts flair but kind of that born-esque
type of fighting where it's a lot more
gritty this is what i've envisioned for
changi this kind of fighting
and so having more of this type of flair
is more my taste where there's a
more of a rhythm and dance and story to
the fighting
i'm getting what i want i'm so excited
let's do this and now we're just going
to keep our eyes peeled during the
actual movie to see if any of the fights
that show up
look kind of like this yeah this is an
actual piece of previz that they made to
be like this
that's the word yeah the previz is when
they shoot it themselves and
maybe it is we'll see anyway guys are
you excited for shanghi
leave your thoughts down below subscribe
click the notification bell hit that
like button
come on marvel bring on the trailer
thank you cosmic
subscribe to him too peace